what up space fam golson here from anime
outpour and i'm back at it again with
another one piece video this time a
video dedicated entirely to luffy's dad
the so-called world's worst criminal
which by the way is like the best and
coolest title to hold in the world of
one piece the dude is shrouded in
mystery and today we'll be going in
depth into dragon his devil fruit his
bounty and his true power so make sure
to stay tuned for this one channel the
pirate king or revolutionary within and
smash that like button if you want to
see more one piece videos like this one
be a smashing pirate king never a
passing orochi make this the video
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
and now without further ado let's jump
into it spoilers and all monkey d dragon
is 55 years old right now he has a face
tattoo he's the supreme commander of the
revolutionary army and as i mentioned he
holds the title for being the world's
worst criminal or the world's most
heinous criminal if you want to use
funimation's translation and as the
story goes on this character has only
grown more and more hype even if he
isn't included frequently into the main
story his birthday is also october 5th
which i include for no other reason than
because my birthday is also in october
and that's definitely not a coincidence
hashtag oktobergang now let's first go
over some hype things that we do know
about this mysterious figure 24 years
ago he was at the pirate king's
execution as a 31 year old no face
tattoo yet notably dragon's face does
not look happy when we see it in episode
849 of the one piece anime and even
though it was a sunny clear day when the
execution begins after the pirate king
aka the freest man in the world is
executed by the world government it
starts to rain and dragon is shown with
a super serious face and frown with rain
falling on and around him i'll go into
why these details are very significant
soon enough but for now we might want to
question this sudden shift in the
weather since even if it was pathetic
fallacy and the sky was crying so to
speak to reflect the sadness of some
characters or the situation there were
other characters there who were smiling
or laughing not everyone was as
seemingly upset as dragon was now is
this enough to assume dragon's mood
caused the sudden change in weather on
its own no of course not but combined
with luffy's adventures in the same town
22 years after roger's execution
dragon's connection to the weather
becomes harder and harder to ignore at
log town thanks to buggy luffy gets
trapped on the execution platform sanji
and zoro are too far to save him from
buggy's sword luffy himself thinks it's
over he says sorry i'm a goner while
smiling just like the pirate king and
just then when the blade is about to
take his helpless head a lightning bolt
comes down thanks to the storm that has
suddenly appeared it burns buggy and
freeze luffy i don't know about you but
i don't believe oda would make this a
coincidence or argue it's just fate that
luffy must survive no matter what after
all that would kill any tension
throughout the series because we know he
can never be killed because fate itself
will intervene every time obviously we
know our protagonists won't die but
there needs to be a good explanation for
why he doesn't or it will feel cheap and
unrewarding smoker goes on to point out
how the weather is helping the straw
hats in several other ways not only did
it free luffy from certain death the
sudden downpour keyword sudden wet their
gunpowder and the wind is blowing toward
the west giving the straw hats a
tailwind smoker asks is this just a
coincidence it's as though some kind of
force is willing this man's survival so
even smoker is not convinced that this
could be a coincidence smoker vows that
he won't let luffy escape but then on
chapter 100 we see him monkey d dragon
himself who we don't know yet is
actually luffy's father last time the
sudden change in weather during roger's
execution was accompanied with dragon's
frown but this time the sudden change in
weather allowed the man similar to roger
aka luffy to escape and dragon is shown
smiling goldie rogers words are brought
up and i quote these things cannot be
stopped and inherited strength of will
one's dreams the ebb and flow of the
ages as long as people hunger for
freedom these things will exist end
quote upon seeing luffy as a pirate now
dragon says to himself a pirate a not a
bad idea clearly he loves the idea of
freedom just like luffy and sees luffy's
career path as a good choice and
potentially aligned with freedom just
like his own path after all we learn
dragons the leader of the
revolutionaries later and the worst
criminal in the world knowing what we
know now namely that luffy had the sun
god nika fruit based on the mythical
warrior of liberation who the oppressed
prayed to we realized that dragon if he
knew the truth about luffy's fruit which
is entirely possible has a huge reason
to save luffy here aside from luffy just
being his son for the revolutionaries
there is no figure more important than
the living and breathing sun god nika
who is like a beacon of hope for all of
those being controlled and oppressed by
the world government and the celestial
dragons true luffy hadn't awakened it
yet but the possibility was there and
you know the leader of the
revolutionaries wouldn't allow that
possibility to be snuffed out if he
could help it just as that awakened
fruit is the world government's worst
nightmare it's also the greatest dream
of the revolutionaries as if oda didn't
give us enough clues that dragon was
helping luffy here smoker captures luffy
and so once again luffy is in need of
saving smoker tells luffy his luck has
run out but suddenly dragon appears to
smoke her shock smoker tells dragon the
government's after his head a comment
that seems ridiculously obvious in
retrospect and dragon simply replies the
world is waiting for our answer then a
strong blast of wind frees luffy from
smoker allowing him to escape for the
second unlikely time smoker even asks
why is dragon helping luffy clearly
suggesting that smoker knows the weather
or at least the wind is a part of
dragon's power dragon responds what
reason would i have to get in the way of
another man's voyage his response goes
with his ideology of freedom but it also
lets him avoid answering the obvious
that he didn't want his son and the
future sun god to be extinguished
despite the fact that smoker knows
dragon must be way more wanted than
luffy he chooses to keep going after
luffy which is a testament to dragon's
power clearly smoker knows that trying
to capture someone as powerful as dragon
is pointless for him and would be
ultimately fruitless much later during
chapter 432 garp tells luffy that his
father is monkey d dragon the leader of
the revolutionaries and that dragon told
garp he saw luffy off at logtown
everyone's reaction to this information
is telling people fall over with tears
in their eyes when dragon is mentioned
there is what can only be described as
pure horror in some of their faces i'm
talking sweat bulging eyes gaping jaws a
shocked sanji calls luffy an idiot for
not knowing who dragon is and nami calls
dragon a really dangerous man only zorro
maintains his usual stoic cool and again
it just makes you love zorro all the
more but this isn't about zorro back to
a sweating robin who is explaining that
pirates usually don't attack the
government or navy on their own but
there is a force trying to directly
challenge the world government that's
the revolutionary army the man who is
leading them is dragon by now his
ideology has spread to many nations of
the world causing them to rebel against
the world government many nations have
already collapsed naturally the
government is angry and dragon the
mastermind behind it all is known as the
world's worst criminal the government is
continually searching for him but to no
avail he is a man of mystery no one
knows anything about him end quote and
this might be a good opportunity to
squeeze in the bonus information about
dragon we got from his bible card we're
told originally dragon was a citizen of
goa kingdom at a certain point in his
life dragon realized how rotten the
world truly was and became convinced
that it was his duty to change the world
for the better because of that he
founded the revolutionary army the army
was founded sometime between 24 to 19
years ago between roger's death and
luffy's birth he values sincerity and
discipline in his army above all else
and his main objective is peace battle
and war victories are seen as a means to
this peaceful end and not as something
to be enjoyed in other words he doesn't
like war but knows it's necessary for
freedom and peace it's hinted that he
has a secret but even if it's revealed
we're told it's not a secret that would
affect the way his subordinates feel
about him lastly he is heavily connected
with cuba known for their own revolution
his ship is called viento granma viento
is the spanish word for wind while
grandma is the ship that fidel castro
used to start the cuban revolution
furthermore his favorite food is a cuban
snack and to further emphasize the
importance of wind to his character in
one piece gigantic battle a nintendo ds
game dragon can unleash a gust of wind
to blow his opponents away not only is
wind perfect for his character in the
sense that he represents the winds of
change but clearly his powers allow him
to utilize wind at the very least and in
my view it's highly likely that he can
use all kinds of weather based powers to
his advantage i personally think that
that lightning bolt that freed luffy was
dragon's work and its perfect timing and
aim can't be explained through wind
powers alone rather than being sure he
has a weather weather fruit though i'd
like the idea personally of dragon
having a dragon fruit it may be a little
bit too on the nose but in mythology
dragons controlled the weather including
rain as mentioned we saw rain both at
roger's execution and luffy's attempted
execution it said that eastern dragons
called weatherlords can summon a storm
when angered which in my view sort of
clicks with how it started raining when
dragon was upset during roger's
execution as a man who loves freedom he
was upset to see the freest man being
executed by the corrupted system he
hates so much now i'm not going to
narrow it down to a specific dragon and
myth since oda can just take what he
wants from different ones and put it
into one fruit but one mythical dragon
in particular named yin long in chinese
myth or the responding dragon was
associated with water and rain doesn't
it seem fitting that the responding
dragon fruit would go to the man who
says the world is waiting for our answer
in other words responds this dragon gets
its responding dragon name from the fact
that if people cried out to him for more
or less reign he would have mercy and
respond to their pleas and was even
associated with giving gifts to mankind
i think that all fits really well with
dragon's character who also wants to
give the gift of freedom to the people
who are crying out for it furthermore
we've seen from kaido's dragon form that
mythical zones like that can use
multiple powers rather than just one and
kaido himself has used flames wind
lightning and more to fight and if you
think there can only ever be one
mythical zone dragon fruit which doesn't
really make sense since there are a lot
of mythical dragons then we're still
good since technically kaido has a fish
fish fruit anyways now i like to believe
that dragon has such a dragon fruit that
can control the weather as one of its
powers and he does even have a dragon
design on his ship which could be
another clue but whether it's that kind
of fruit or not the point is he can
control the weather and he is viewed as
being super strong and the most
dangerous to the point that the world
government hasn't captured him even if
they're reportedly always trying to we
also find out that a dragon surrounded
by wind saved sabo from drowning and
then we saw the two of them surrounded
by wind land on the revolutionary ship
to be specific in the anime we see his
right foot land and then his left as if
he was just flying and for me after
everything we've seen i think it's
pretty safe to assume that he can fly
whether he's a dragon or not and that
would also partly explain why he's so
hard to capture he'd never be beast or
stranded on one island plus if anyone
actually approaches him with a ship or
ships on sea he can totally use his
weather control to ruin their boat or
boats making him practically untouchable
we saw how important weather can be in
chapter 0 where roger pulled off a draw
against shiki despite being outnumbered
and in a desperate situation because
half of shiki's fleet sank and he had
his unfortunate incident due to the
raging weather it's even possible that
roger had someone on his crew with the
same power that dragon now has and used
it to escape safely from a seemingly
impossible situation ivankov has also
nodded towards dragon's strength when
commenting that luffy being dragon son
explains his superhuman vitality since
he's as far as we know garp's son and
since he's related to luffy being his
dad it's easy to assume that dragon is
insanely strong garp is the hero of the
marines who fought alongside roger and
god valley and together they beat the
rock's pirates a crew that included
rocks big mom kaido whitebeard and many
more legendary pirates meanwhile at 19
luffy dragon's son just beat kaido the
so-called strongest creature in the
world and the living yonko with the
highest bounty when i previously made my
monkey d dragon and his commander's
explained video a video that you should
check out if you want to know more about
dragon's army i didn't get into whether
dragon was above yonko level or not but
i will here now that we saw his 19 year
old son beat kaido i must say it's very
unlikely that dragon is weaker than the
yonko now we don't know shanks's full
power so i won't get into that here but
i would wager based on how shonen tend
to work that dragon whose true power and
potential has been kept a secret all
this time is stronger than big mom and
potentially stronger than kaido too it
just wouldn't make sense that a dude who
gets such reactions from people who's
related to garp and luffy who's more
wanted than any yonko by the government
and yet they can't touch him who's been
shrouded in mystery and not shown off
yet will be weaker than big mom more
than ever i firmly believe he's at least
above some yonko and the fact that he's
considered the world's worst criminal
will lead me to assume at this point
that he has the highest current bounty
of any living character after all unlike
the yonko he's actively attacking the
government winning battles all over the
place against them and is undoubtedly
their biggest threat furthermore oda has
revealed all yonko bounties but chosen
to keep dragons a mystery all this time
making it highly unlikely that it will
be something low and disappointing for
the fun of it i'll guess that dragon's
bounty is 5 billion which would make him
currently the most wanted known criminal
in addition to the world's worst
criminal the thing that may hold him
back from an even higher bounty is that
the bounty of his commanders aren't that
high which by extension makes him seem
like less of a threat than if he had
multiple commanders with a billion plus
bounties but let me know your thoughts
do you agree that dragon is yonko level
or above and has an especially high
bounty or do you think i'm
overestimating him based on my prior
knowledge of how shonen work and on the
dragon info we've gotten so far it would
truly be shocking to me if luffy's dead
dragon himself was weaker than someone
like big mom there's like zero percent
chance of that happening in my mind but
nothing is guaranteed at this point
except that you should smash that like
button if you enjoyed this video and
want to see more like it be a smashing
pirate king rather than passing on rochi
make this video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss new
one-piece videos and updates leave a
comment below on what you think dragon's
bounty will actually be and if you are
correct when the actual bounty comes out
i will try to shout you out in a future
video or chapter review and even though
i said i think dragon might have the
highest living bounty currently click
the video on screen now to see why i
think his son will surpass his father's
bounty soon in the video i go over
luffy's post-wanna bounty and use past
evidence to narrow down the exact number
so make sure not to miss that one and
i'll see you there